Probably he called me and he asked me if
I would like to be the night king
and I don't heard Night King. I just heard king
and I said I can be
any King in all the world
I think he's angry.
He don't want to be Night King.
The children of the forest, they change him.
and now he's okay
you want me to be Night King
well, okay now I kill you.
Camera. 3...2...1...Action!
Instead of it being a death like that
it's just a...
before you even get to be surprised
party yeah okay that's good
that really helps
should be any more time.
yeah
Miguel he show me the way move
from A to B is it looks like easy but...
is definitely not like...
I sometimes I realize
being actor is not easy to be
it's better to be stuntman.
Hi everyone it's Charlie
this is going to be my video for
the Game of Thrones season 8 bonus
episode that they aired last night
providing a whole bunch of extra context
for the characters we learned a whole
bunch more about the night king there
was some funny moments so we'll break it
all down if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the Song of Ice and Fire Game of Thrones
videos I'll be doing videos for the
prequel series in the next week or so
they're shooting that right now and then
obviously HBO is going to air His Dark
Materials and Watchmen later this year
I'll be doing videos for that stuff -
I'll just remind everybody about the big
stuff that's coming like the Amazon Lord
of the Ring series at the end of the
video also changing the giveaway to
something different at the end of the
video - careful for spoilers for
everything through season 8 I'm assuming
most of you probably seen it by now but
top 10 WTF and Easter eggs starting with
number 10 the actors got their scripts
for the final season three days before
the first table read which are actually
seeing play out right here not everybody
chose to read the scripts though Kit
Harington is actually one of the prime
examples of somebody who didn't read
through every single one of his scripts
before they sat down to look at it for
the first time you watch him here
learning about the scene at the end
where he kills Daenerys for the first
time as he actually reads through it his
reaction is priceless so it all starts
with Tyrians conversation with Tyrion
trying to convince Jon Snow to kill
Daenerys then this would have cut right
to the actual scene where he's doing the
deed with Daenerys in the iron throne
room before drogon burns the iron throne
standing before the iron throne
Dany steps forward and kisses the man
she loves the perfect kiss their eyes
closed his hand behind her head her hand
on his cheek Danny's eyes open suddenly
as she draws a sharp breath Jon's eyes
open as well already filling with tears
for a moment neither moves as if moving
will make this real we see Jon with his
hand still on the hilt of the dagger he
just lodged in Danny's heart
her strength leaves her and she
collapses to the marble he keeps her in
his arms and she falls kneeling down to
the floor beside her he looks down at
what he's done terrible and necessary
the funniest thing about that isn't so
much kid Harrington reacting to it
because he looks like his mind is
absolutely blown he's broken he's like
oh my god I can't believe this it's
actually watching all the other actors
who read the scene and knew was going to
happen watching him and reacting to his
reaction like you see Emilia Clarke who
knew it was going to happen sort of
cringing under the table putting her
hand in her face watching him freak out
reading it for the first time nine kana
leave he'll the actor the plays Varys
also learned about his death for the
first time when they're reading here you
see a throw his script into the middle
of the table while Emilia Clarke is
still mid-sentence reading the actual
scene I told you you did I didn't pass
the first of my main breaker of chains
and mother of dragons sentencing today
Shekhar's drogon spews fire on him but
we don't watch our old friend burn
instead we see the reactions of those
who knew him tearing in his heartbroken
John is disturbed great world sees this
as the just execution of a traitor they
also read through jours death scene this
is Bryan cogman actually reading the
scene Ian Glen looks like he's either
super Pro about it or he already read
this a couple days ago so he was
prepared for when they actually started
working on it really cool side note to
Bryan cogman here the person who was
reading that scene has been a writer on
the show for a long time he's sort of
the Song of Ice and Fire book expert on
the writing staff who was also
responsible for answering really
specific questions about characters when
they were writing new seasons he was
working on one of the Game of Thrones
spin-offs that they decided not to do
early on maybe that was the adult Aria
in the West series that George R Martin
has talked about because he has talked
about doing a sequel with Arya to his
Song of Ice and Fire story once he
finished his dream of spring but
obviously that's a long long ways off
because they're not doing his sequel
series he's actually gone on to Amazon's
Lord of the Rings series we won't be
getting episode
for that for a while because they don't
start shooting it till later this year
obviously I will do Lord of the Rings
episode videos but I don't think it's
going to get here till like the very end of
next year or 2021 so we'll be watching
The Witcher Netflix series The Watchmen
HBO series Rick and Morty season 4 in
the Game of Thrones prequel series
before Lord of the Rings gets here
number 8 the very first scene that they
filmed for season 8 was Samwell learning
that Daenerys burned his father and
brother for the first time you can
actually see them rehearsing here with
David Nutter probably one of the best
directors that they've ever had on Game
of Thrones
everything was shot completely out of
order they had a lot of really cool
stuff about the Crypt whites of the
ancient stark ancestors that rose up
during the big Episode three battle 7
the night King actor Vladimir fertig
also in charge of all their huge fight
scenes he's also one of their big fight
choreographers because that's what he
did for like thirty plus years before he
actually started acting in front of the
camera him becoming the night King
didn't happen till much later I'll
explain that in a second because that's
definitely on my list here all of his
night King scenes but this is the scene
of him
teaching them about the cleganebowl
fight and you see him rehearsing a lot
of the other fights too because he's
been a stunt double for a long time too
so anytime there's a really crazy weapon
scene that needs to happen
he usually stands in for an actor if
he's the right size remember Ned Stark
versus Arthur Dayne at the Tower of joy
during season 6 episode 3 that was
Vladimir verdict this guy here who was
actually doubling for Arthur Dayne duel
building dawn in the other sword while
he was fighting all those other people
this is the scene of him doing it in
real time
seeing how good he is with the sword
don't you feel kind of bad that you
never got to see him as the night king
dual wielding or at a really big sword
fight with someone else
Valyrian steel would stand up against
the night King's sword but the good news
is is that because they're doing a much
bigger much deeper version of the White
Walkers in the night King during the
game of Thrones blood moon prequel
series maybe he'll come back for that
even if he doesn't continue to play the
on screen night king he can still play
his double and do any big sword fights
or any big fight scenes that he might
get into 6 if you guys noticed they
basically followed this one stark
soldier through most of the documentary
he was kind of a star c-3po r2d2 style
doing the Kurosawa George Lucas thing
where the story follows some of the
lesser actors and lesser characters less
important people that you wouldn't
normally hear about in the actual
episodes his real name is Andrew McClay
but his name on the show is Abra Dale
strong beard has been playing one of the
Starks soldiers for the past five or six
years this is his quick intro clip where
he just talks about himself a little bit
high stock absolute best at the end
maximum weight the direwolf say joe's
coup and art stark fighting for a dark
ravines there's a scene at the end of
the documentary where he's sort of
closing up shop getting ready to leave
for the final time talking about the
very first time he came to audition in
how his house almost burnt down in a
fire but he still made it to work the
next day like that is hardcore
dedication right there vibe the same
actor also talks about the big battle
scene and gives you some more context
for how big their armies were and this
is actually a bit of a surprise for me
so he says that there were a hundred and
twenty thousand White's in the night
Kings white Walker army against their
18,000 combined forces so that means
that when you add the unsullied the
Dothraki the northern soldiers including
the Knights of the Vale and the Starks
soldiers they only have 18,000 people in
and around Winterfell and then what
happened is is after the battle even
though it seemed like all the Dothraki
were dead basically by the time you get
to the big battle on episode 5 in the
finale
they're supposed to be at 50% of their
original strength so I know it was
really weird when you go from episode 3
where it seems like most of them are
dead to this final scene with Daenerys
giving her big dictator speech and it
seems like they just completely
respawned
all the Dothraki and all the unsullied
the night king actor also talks a little
bit about his death scene with bran they
actually have a really funny moment here
if you've ever watched that HBO show
extras it's just a funny scene about all
the lesser actors on TV shows done as a
half-hour comedy they could actually do
a show like that just with Game of
Thrones extras for really important
context though because they're filming
the scene of Arya killing the night king
is that they explain when they're
reading through the script that she's
actually jumping off a giant pile of
whites that's in the background that you
just can't see obviously the way they
filmed it is they have her on a harness
and she's flying through the air but
within the actual scene Arya is jumping
off a pile of dead white sand that's how
she winds up getting so high in the air
so it makes a little more sense usually
you only see that stuff if you read the
scripts and sometimes they don't always
make those available publicly if you
really like to dig that deep into stuff
George RR Martin's scripts for the Game
of Thrones episodes that he wrote on the
series are fascinating they have so many
extra notes and deleted scenes that they
never actually wound up filming I might
do a separate video about that at some
point there's a lot of stuff that George
our Martin wanted to put in his game of
Thrones episodes they just never wound
up getting to either because it was too
expensive or because it wound up being a
character that they didn't bring onto
the show or because it gave away a big
twist that was happening later on or he
gave you too many clues about something
that they were planning on doing 3 this
is actually kind of funny this is a
trick that they pulled during the big
Great Council scene they were filming in
Spain so they went back to the place
where they film all the dragon pit
scenes in Spain but in order to deceive
all the paparazzi that were trying to
camp this set they brought back a whole
bunch of really big extra characters
that had nothing to do with the actual
final version of the scene they flew
jaqen H'ghar to walk around like you
just see him standing around in his
faceless man outfit people wondering is
jaqen H'ghar coming back for the final
season i didn't hear any really big
rumors about that but maybe that's what
started people asking about Jack and
agar they brought the wave back and they
brought the knight King back to that big
council scene I remember hearing a lot
of people asking about the night King
mysteriously showing up in the finale
like he's coming back they're going to
bring the night King back for a big
scene apparently they were probably
looking at behind-the-scenes pictures of
this and they saw him walking around on
set and that's probably what started
those rumors they also flew a lot of
extra people to the hotel in Spain
nearby where they were filming those
scenes like they brought Kit Harington
in even though they didn't put him on
set there's a funny behind-the-scenes
picture that people are mistakenly
thinking is Kit Harington in the dragon
pit putting makeup on arya like why is
kit harington doing Arya's makeup here
he does look a lot like hit harrington
but that's because he's kit harington's
jon snow stand-in so that's why he's
doing aurea's makeup here it's just
there to deceive the paparazzi I think
they also flew the actor that plays
Rhaegar Targaryen into the hotel but I
don't think I ever saw him on set or
anything like that
- this is the final scene of the night
King it was just him doing that big
aerial dragon fight they were just doing
a little bit of extra stunt work and
green screen stuff for that for when
Daenerys knocks him off of vissarion's
back and he falls all the way to the
ground you can see from all this stuff
that nobody had more fun filming Game of
Thrones Season 8th in the night King
actor in a bird ale strong beard here
but number one the final scenes for the
biggest characters so you have kid
Harrington's last seen here which is
also grey worms last scene and Davos is
last seen surprisingly it was just the
scene of them walking up while grey worm
is executing these Lannister soldiers
with their big stand up but kid
Harrington gave one of the best epic
goodbye speeches
I love this show and it is never been a
job for me it's been my life and that
this will always be the greatest thing
I'll ever do and their problem we've
been just interestingly enough Denise's
last seen was not her actual death scene
it was just a green-screen insert of the
waterfall scene from Episode one after
they dismount the Dragons they're a
couple of their Game of Thrones bonus
videos that I'm working on I'll also
start doing prequel series videos as we
learn more about that but don't forget
we also have The Witcher Netflix series
coming up later this year Amazon's Lord
of the Rings series HBO's Watchmen TV series
Rick and Morty season 4 and a whole bunch
of other really big stuff I'll also be
doing Westworld season 3 videos when
that comes back next year - I've gotten
a lot of questions about Westworld so
don't worry about that leave all your
bonus video requests in the comments
below if there's any really big
questions you still have about big plot
points or mythology or anything like
that let me know in the comments if you
want me to change the weekly Game of
Thrones giveaway to something else
- besides HBO now like the books the
blu-rays whatever you guys want then
I'll say congratulations to last week's
giveaway winner Aiden Rahimi
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your details click
here for my Game of Thrones finale Q&A
and click here for my Game of Thrones
Season 8 deleted scenes and alternate
ending video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight